hello everybody welcome to another tango
technique class at home i hope you are
all doing fine today's class will be
very similar to the class we did before
in the previous video
because we will repeat exactly the same
exercises but we will introduce a new
element today which is rotation of your
torso yeah torsion or dissociation yeah
by doing this we will make the exercises
much more complete yeah you will need
your stick
and also the metronome because we want
to keep a steady reference for the
timing of our movements you know we want
to make them regular and the metronome
helps us with that
so
let's see how all these um elements with
the addition of uh torsion work together
to improve your tango first of all you
are bending and stretching your standing
leg yeah this of course works on your
balance and also works on the strength
of your leg yeah you will develop the
muscles and this of course will help
balance speed and everything else
then
you are also projecting with your free
leg in your exercises yeah front side
and back different directions you're
also bending the knee
so this helps you to improve the control
of your free leg yeah so that you can
use it without affecting your axis
without affecting your bodies okay
then
by adding the stick to the exercises you
also work at the same time your posture
because
you will hold the stick above your head
again
and in order to do this properly you
have to raise your ribcage
and also engage the muscles of your
upper body yeah you should not just use
the arms you have to use the torso
to hold the stick more than your arms
and by keeping this feeling when you
dance you will improve your axis your
posture and also it will be easier to
dance with you because your posture will
be straight and make it easy to follow
you okay
and then today we are also introducing
this movement and this will help you in
even more areas for example
it will help you in coordination because
you have to coordinate
where do you go
and when with the torso together with
what happens with the free leg yeah the
movements have to be coordinated so this
will help you that and also it will help
you in your dissociation
because when you move the torso and you
move the free leg you don't want
the movements that are happening on each
to influence each other yeah to to
contaminate each other yeah so whatever
you do with a free leg and whatever
rotation you do with the torso you want
to keep them separate okay so it will
help you on that so that makes the
exercises very very complete and they
will enhance your thumbs a lot okay so i
hope you like it let's go for the warm
up okay one month so start with
feet together straight posture
shoulders relax
and head straight and looking forward
and we start with shoulder rotations
remember to do them big and slow and not
to use the arrows yeah don't do this
keep the elbows relaxed okay let's do
eight
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
and eight
okay now we do arm circles remember to
keep the arms straight all the time
don't bend the elbows and when you open
the arms pass the hands behind the back
so that you stretch the chest muscles
okay and we do it
one
two
keep the shoulders down
three
four
five
six
seven
and
eight
okay
now we stretch the side of our torso we
raise an arm make sure the arm is
straight then we slide the hand that is
down down our leg until we can touch the
side of our knee we hold the stretch
three seconds and then we come up again
and we lower the arm and we'll repeat to
the other side okay
so let's
do it four times to each side okay
let's go
one
go down
hold it
and up
one
go down
hold it
and up
two
go down your leg
hold it
and up
two
throw down your leg
hold it
and up
three
down
all the stretch
and up
three
go down
hold it
and up
and the last one four
go down hold the stretch
and
up four
go down
hold it
and up
okay now open your legs a little bit
wider than your shoulders and bend the
knees a little bit keep your hips
straight all the time looking forward
and your head also straight and looking
forward
make a circle with your arms
keep the elbows
relaxed and the hands below your chest
and then rotate your torso left and
right remember the hip doesn't rotate
the head doesn't rotate yeah and the
torsion is on your ribcage below the
ribcage here yeah
keep the hands always in front of your
chest
so that your arms don't
work independently of the torso you want
to work with your back okay so let's do
it eight times to each side twice okay
let's go
um
one
[Music]
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight eight more one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
and eight okay now stretch the knees but
keep the legs open
grab your hips with your hands
and then
go forward bend forward from the hip
until your back is parallel with the
floor
and then go down
with your head
and bounce three times
one two three
and then go up slowly yeah
now one thing about the arms
you can
grab your hips or you can put the hands
behind your head yeah and do it like
this
the difference is that if you hold your
hips the weight of the arm is closer to
your center so
your back doesn't need to
work so much the muscles of your back
don't need to work so much because you
are not lifting so much weight but if
you put your hands
on behind your head like this now the
weight of the arms is much further away
from your center yeah it's far away so
your back needs to work more to lift
more weight yeah so behind your head is
a little bit more work for your back
it's more difficult
on your hips is a bit easier the back
doesn't need to lift so much so it's up
to you yeah
today i will do it with my hands and
hips
okay so let's do it three times bend
forward one
bounce
bounce bounce once three times
and then go up
two
go down
bounce bounce bounce
and go up
three
go down
bounce bounce bounce relax
and go up
four
go down
bounce bounce bounce
water
five
go down
bounce bounce bounce
go up
six
go down
bounce bounce bounce very relaxed
go up
seven
go down
pass pass bounce
go up and eight
go down
okay
now
go back with your hip slightly and then
move your hip to the side keeping your
legs straight yeah then move your hip
forward and then to the other side and
then back so we make a big wide circle
with our hips we do it eight times to
one side
and eight times to the side yeah here
you can also choose if you want to have
your hands on your hips or if you want
to have them behind your head today i
will do the exercise with my hands
behind the head okay
so that my torso has more work
stabilizing this extra weight
so let's go
ah
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
and eight
and now eight times in the other
direction
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
and
eight
yeah it's a bit more challenging when
you do it with your hands behind the
head and remember a common mistake with
this exercise is to move only the hip
like this no it's not about this yeah
you have to keep your torso straight all
the time in a diagonal yeah
when the hip goes to the side you do a
diagonal with the torso
okay
good now next one
lower the arms relax them and put your
feet together make sure that your feet
are
exactly parallel and touching each other
okay now grab your hips
or
put your hands under your head
it's all the same yeah just try one that
you like
i will grab my hips and then bend the
knees bounce three times one two three
then stretch the knees go up on your
toes keeping your legs together don't
let them open yeah
hold it for three seconds and then go
down slowly don't go down quickly yeah
go down control slowly and we do it
eight times okay let's go one
bounce bounce bounce
go up
hold it
go down
two
bounce bounce bounce
go up hold it
go down
three
bounce bounce bounce
go up hold it
go down
four
bounce bounce bounce go up hold it
go down
five bounce bounce bounce
go up hold it
go down
six bounce bounce bounce
go up hold it
go down
seven
bounce bounce bounce go up
hold it
go down and eight
balance bounce bounce
go up hold it
and go down
okay last exercise we stretch the back
of our legs so start with feet together
grab your hips and then
go back with one foot whichever you want
and make sure that the heel is on the
floor yeah
and that your knee is straight on the
back leg then bend the knee forward
yeah then you have the front leg then
before until you
feel the back legs stretching and hold
it 25 seconds okay
let's count
one
two
three
four
five
six
eight
nine
ten
one
two
three
four
and five okay now get out of the stretch
by stretching the front knee yeah
and then we move to the other side
so feet together
then move one the other foot back the
distance of a big step
and then make sure that the heel is on
the floor on the ground and that the
knee is completely stretched yeah
then bend
the knee of the forward leg until you
feel the stretch
if you find this position difficult to
hold because of the balance you are
bubbling you can uh put one hand on the
wall like this you adjust the fingers
don't lean on it yeah just just the
fingers
okay if you can't do it without the help
of the wall and then let's count 25
seconds
ten
one
two
three
four
and five
now get out of the stretch slowly by
stretching the front knee okay
and we're ready let's go for the first
exercise okay for the first exercise we
will practice just simple balance and
dissociation you will need your stick
and the metronome and i show you how the
exercise works
so
you start with your feet together and
you hold the stick in front of you with
a wider like this yeah and then you find
your balance
on your standing leg whichever you want
yeah you can mirror me
then you lift your free foot a little
bit just a few centimeters above the
floor to make sure that you're really on
one leg okay and then you lift the stick
above your head and you make sure that
you are lifting the rib cage when you
lift the stick and you engage also the
muscles on your upper back so that your
arms can relax yeah you need to stick
with the torso more than the arms okay
then from here
you do two movements at the same time
you bend the knee of the standing leg so
you go down like this and at the same
time you turn the torso towards
the standing leg like this
and then
you return to the initial position then
you go down again on the same leg you
bend the knee again but this time you
turn the torso to the free leg
like this okay
and then
you return to the initial position
okay
so
um you don't need to turn the torso too
much you don't need to turn 90 degrees
or something
i only turn
45 degrees more or less a diagonal
that's okay yeah and when you turn the
torso you should also take your head
with the torso head and torso look at
the same direction because what we are
doing with the distortion is to imitate
um
the situation where you have to keep
track of your partner yeah you have to
keep looking at your partner so of
course you also want to bring the head
with the toes okay that's the area now a
few tips is when to improve your balance
when you go down
um try to focus
on your standing foot yeah and you're
standing like focus on the leg
yeah that's the most important thing
because then your balance will be more
solid and another tip to improve your
balance is that when you turn the torso
try to make the rotation of your torso
happen as slow as possible
right above your hip yeah the hip of
course doesn't turn the hip always looks
to the front
but you try to make the torsion really
deep really dark here instead of for
example just moving the arms
or doing it with the chest or the
shoulders no
you make it happen
really low
on your abdomen
okay
so every time you turn the torso to one
side you count one repetition yeah one
and two up and we do eight and then we
do it to the other side we don't know
okay
good so
now how do we do this with a metronome
it's going to be like this
we will take two down bits to go down
and two down bits to go up so it will be
very slow yeah it will be like this
yeah
one
two three
four and then to the other side one two
three four yeah so very slow but this
has the advantage of giving you a lot of
strength in your legs and also giving
you time enough to control the movement
very well
and to make sure that
everything is going well okay
so let's do it together eight times
feet together
hold the stick in front of you find your
balance on one leg
then raise the stick make sure your rib
cage is up
and your back is engaged
and then let's do it eight times
one
and up
now the torso to the other side two
um
[Music]
six
eight
and up
okay lower feet and relax your legs
especially your standing leg
okay now we're going eight arms
with the other leg okay so feet together
stick in front of you
find your balance on the other leg now
lift your free foot a little bit and
then raise the stick above your head
and make sure that your rib cage is up
and your back engaged
and now let's use torsion for balance
okay let's do it
one
up
two
on top
[Music]
six
and five
seven
on top
okay
good
if it helps you with violence you could
imagine also that every time you're
going down on your standing leg you're
sitting down on a chair behind you yeah
and you are just
lowering your hip into a chair and
resting on it
also that you are hanging from your
stick yeah the stick is suspended on the
from the ceiling and you're hanging from
it this can also help you
to keep your balance okay great so let's
go to the next exercise okay in this
exercise we will project our free leg
forward okay
and the exercise works like this i'll
show you from the profile
first you put your feet together
straight posture and you hold the stick
in front of you with a wide grip okay
then you find your balance on your
standing leg
whichever you want
and you leave the free foot
uh touching the floor but without weight
okay
then you lift the stick above your head
uh making sure that you are lifting the
ribcage and engaging the
back muscles okay and then
you do three movements at the same time
you project the free leg forward yeah
remember that it's not about how high
the leg goes it's just about projecting
it forward so think about forward and
not up if your foot is only a few
centimeters away from the floor that's
already fine yeah
main thing is that you are on one leg
project the free leg forward at the same
time bend the standing leg so you go
down
and also at the same time
turn your torso
towards the free leg yeah when you turn
the torso you also turn the head yeah
towards one head together why because we
use torsion and tangle most of the times
to keep track of the position of our
partner yeah to keep oriented towards
our partner so that's why you also
should move the head okay so these three
movements happen at the same time
project free leg bend standing leg
torsion
towards the free leg yeah
then on the second movement we bend the
knee until you can touch
your
uh your knee or below the knee with your
free foot then on the third movement you
stretch the free leg and on the fourth
you return to the initial position yeah
so we have four movements
one
two
three
and four
now
uh technical tip
so that the whole exercise is a bit
easier to do two things
the whole time when you do the movement
try to focus on your standing foot yeah
put your attention on your standing foot
so that you keep your axis on top of it
no matter what you do and the second tip
is well for the torsion yeah try to
imagine that the torsion of your torso
is happening as low as possible yeah
right above the hip the hip doesn't move
of course it doesn't rotate the hip
always stays in one direction but the
rotation of your torso is happening as
low as possible
don't do the torsion with the arms or or
with the chest only high because this
will be very bad for your balance yeah
try to imagine that
the torsion is happening right
above your hip okay
this is the first repetition
on the second repetition
is the same thing but this time we turn
the torso towards the
standing leg
yeah to the other side more or less 45
degrees on each direction if you are
more flexible and you can turn more like
90 degrees then great for you yeah i'm
going to turn only 45 degrees okay
that's enough
and then we do it um eight times each
time that we turn the torso towards one
side is one repetition so it's one
two
down and so on okay and we will do it
eight times
and we will use the metronome
to make sure that we are doing our
movements
exactly at the same speed all the time
and that our movements are flowing
continuously and regular
okay so
we will do the movements on each
downbeat yeah down bits are
this yeah
downward
downward one movement per down so it
will be
one
two
three
four
yeah and then to the other side okay
so let's do it together put your feet
together find your balance on one leg
raise the stick
and then let's go eight times
time
one
two three
four
two
three
four
two
three
four
two
three
four
five
two
three
four
six
two
three
four
seven
two
three
four
eight
two
three
four
okay
yeah with the metronome it will be very
clear
if you are accelerating some movement
okay because your movement will have
finished but you will not have heard the
beat yet the other bit is coming so try
to adjust the speed of your movements so
everything starts and finishes
with the beat okay
let's do it to the other side feet
together
find your balance on the other leg now
raise the stick
rib cage up
back muscles engaged
and let's go eight times together
one
two
three
four
two
three
four
two
three
four
two
three
four
five
two
three
four
six
two
three
four
seven
two
three
four
eight
two
three
four
okay
another three you can use to help your
balance is to imagine that
when you are flexing the knee of your
standing leg you are going down it's
like you are sitting on a chair imagine
there is a chair
behind you and you are just sitting on
the chair
maybe this image helps you okay let's do
it one more time to one side on the
other side okay
feet together
find your balance on the first leg
raises stick ribcage up back active and
extra eight times
one
two
three
four
one
two
three
four
two
three
four
two
three
four
five two
three
four
six
two
three
four
seven
two
three
four
eight
two
three
four
okay
this is one more time
to decide now
remember the tips focus on the standing
foot so everything you do you keep your
axis on top of it
make the rotation happen as low as
possible above your hip right above your
hip yeah
and imagine that you're sitting down if
it helps you okay
so when it's time to decide
find your balance
stick up
repeat up and let's go eight times
one
two
three
four
one
two
three
four
two
three
four
two
three
four
five
two
three
four
six
two three
four
seven
two
three
four
eight
two
three
four
okay
great
let's go to the next exercise okay in
this exercise we will project our free
leg to the side
okay
an exercise follows the same logic of
all the others start your feet together
hold the stick in front of you with a
wide grip then find your balance on one
leg on your standing leg whichever you
want you can mirror me if you want and
then keep your free foot on the floor
but without weight then lift
your stick above your head making sure
that you are lifting your whole ribcage
and then the back muscles are engaged so
that your arms can relax and then on the
first movement there are three things
happening
you are projecting your free leg to the
side remember that is not about lifting
it a lot yeah it's only about projecting
it and lifting your foot just a few
centimeters above the ground that's
enough yeah
also your you bend your standing leg
down like this yeah
and
also you turn your torso towards the
standing leg
like this yeah just 45 degrees is enough
if you can turn more
good for you yeah
and then you
that's the first movement then you bend
the knee of the free leg
close the leg as much as you can like
for a venture or an alignment and then
stretch the free leg
and then
you return to the initial position
so four movements yeah
one
two
three
four
yeah
and then on the next repetition
is the same thing but instead of turning
the torso towards your uh
stunning leg you turn the torso towards
your free leg like this
yeah
one
two
three
four okay
and then you do it again
we do it eight times in total
every time you turn the torso to one
direction is one repetition so it's one
two three four and so on yeah remember
that this yeah
focus on your standing foot this is the
most important tip this is tip number
one yeah no matter what you do focus on
your standing foot and make sure that no
matter which movement you are doing you
keep your axis on top of the standing
foot
the second tip that will help you with
balance is for the torsion
make it happen as low as possible right
above your hip here yeah
don't turn the arms only or only the
chest yeah
make the torsion deep
close to your center
yeah then it will be easier
okay and the last tip is if it helps you
you can imagine that you are sitting
down on a chair yeah behind
yeah then maybe this will make you feel
more secure more confident with the
movement okay
and we will use a metronome of course
and we will do our movements
always on the downbeat of the metronome
yeah so
one
two
from the beginning of the exercise to
the end of the exercise so that you make
sure that your movements are
continuous fluid and regular okay
okay let's go eight times
so feet together find your balance
stick above your head rib cage up
back active and let's go eight times
one
two
three
four
two turn to the other side two
three
four
two
three
four
[Music]
two
three
four
five
two
three
four
six two
three
four
seven
two
three
four
eight
two
three
four
okay
relax relax standing leg and now let's
do it to the side okay so feet together
find your balance
on the other leg
yeah
lift the stick repeat up back active and
let's go eight times
one
two
three
four
two
4 two
three
four
five
two
three
four
six
two
three
four
seven
two
three
four
eight
two
three
and four okay relax the shoulders relax
your standing leg and now let's repeat
it one more time to both sides and this
time i'll show you from behind
so that you can
see the other side of the exercise
especially the free leg okay
good so feet together
now find your balance on the first leg
that you used before
and then
put your stick above your head
lift your rib cage and activate your
back yeah
and then
let's go eight times
remember that in the first repetition
you turn towards your standing leg and
on the second repetition you turn to the
freeway okay
let's go
one
two
three
four
two
three
four
two
three
four four
two
three
four
five
two
three
four
six
two
three
four
seven
two
three
four
and eight
two
three
and four
yeah
when i show it towards the wall is a bit
harder for me to balance because i just
have a white ball in front of me with
nothing nothing to look at and the
shadow is moving as well so it's a bit
weird
but i'm doing my best and actually if
you wobble with your balance but you
fight to keep it that's even a better
exercise so you can use problems and
mistakes to your advantage okay
it will give you a lot of strength on
your standing leg okay
good so as we understand to the other
side
legs together feet together find your
balance on the other leg
be more away from the wall
yeah like this then
stick above your head
rib cage up back active
and let's go eight times
one
two
three
four
two
three
four
two
three
four
two
three
four
five
two
three
four
six
two
three
four
seven
two
three
four
and eight
two
three
four
okay
um
when you lift the leg when you project
the leg try to avoid tilting with the
third shoe to the opposite side because
this
especially combining the torsion
will really show your balance yeah so
really try to keep
your torso
straight yeah straight
i'm not tilted okay
good let's go to the next exercise okay
on the last exercise we'll project our
leg backwards yeah going back like this
and the exercise follows the same logic
as all the others so
it works like this you stand with your
feet together holding the stick in front
of you with a wide grip yeah
then you find your balance on one leg on
your standing leg whichever you prefer
i'm using the right now and keep the
foot the free foot on the floor
without weight but touching the floor
okay
then raise the stick above your head
making sure your rib cage is up and your
back engaged and then
the first uh on the first downbeat you
do three movements at the same time
you project the leg back making sure
that your knee is straight and your foot
is just a few centimeters
above the floor yeah you also bend the
standing leg the knee of the standing
leg so you go down and you also turn the
torso
towards the standing leg like this yeah
then on the second down bit you be you
bend the knee of the free leg
on the third you stretch the freeway and
on the fourth
you return to the initial position
okay
now the next repetition is the same
but
you turn the torso towards the free leg
yeah like this the other direction then
you bend the knee you stretch and you
return to the initial position yeah
every time you turn the torso to one
side is one repetition and we do eight
okay
now
um
uh one thing about
the torso and the leg usually when the
torso and the leg are doing different
things
they still want to move together yeah
so for example
when you turn the torso towards your
standing leg like this
it might be that the free leg wants to
follow the torso so it opens to the side
yeah
so you should try to avoid that yeah
when you turn the torso
try
as much as you can that your leg is
really going back yeah
so you should feel
uh like a spiral
going from your hand all the way down
your arm through your uh side of the
torso towards the leg on the foot it
should be like a spiral okay
also for the same reason when you turn
the torso towards your free leg maybe
the free leg wants to follow the torso
and starts crossing behind the standing
leg
so don't let that happen yeah
when you turn the torso to the free leg
make sure that the free leg is still
back yeah
also when you project the leg yeah
whichever direction your torso goes
maybe the dorsal tilts a bit forward
because it's trying to follow the leg
like this yeah and of course if this
happens
and if you combine it with the torsion
with the
you won't be able to keep the balance so
in principle whatever you do with the
torso and your free leg you have to cut
them you have to separate them so that
their movements don't affect each other
okay
so let's do it
eight times
together
with a metronome and we use each
downward for each movement okay
so
find your balance on the standing leg
stick over your head
rib cage up back engage core tight
foot standing foot flat on the floor and
then let's do it eight times together
one
two
three
four
two
three
four
two
three four
four
two
three
four
five
two
three
four
six
two
three
four
seven
two
three
four
and eight
two
three
four okay relax the arms relax the legs
and remember the tips to improve your
balance and to be able to keep the
balance
concentrate on your foot on your
standing foot yeah and your standing leg
and make the rotation of your torso
happen as slow as possible above the hip
yeah
really low
okay
so let's do that arms to this side
find your balance
uh stick over your head
rib cage up
and let's go eight times together
and
one
two
three
four
two
three
four
two
three
four
two
three four
five
two
three
four
six
two
three
four
seven
two
three
four
and eight
two
three
four
okay
good
so let's do it again
to this side to the first side so feet
together
find your balance relax the shoulders
and then raise the stick
above your head
and repeat up
let's do it eight times
and
one
two
three
four
two
two three
four
three
two
four
three
five
two
three
four
six
two
three
four
seven
two
three
four
and eight
two
three
and four okay lowering speed relax the
shoulders relax your standing leg
especially
and then let's do it one last time
to this side so feet together
find your balance
on your standing leg
the stick
yeah make sure your rib cage is up and
the back muscles are engaged yeah and
then let's do it eight times together
slowly with a medicine
ah
one
two
three
four
two
three
four
two
three
four
two three
five
two
three
four
six
two
three
four
seven
two
three
four
eight
two
three
and four
okay
great
so
we are done
and
if you keep practicing these exercises i
know that they are difficult
but they will give you a lot of strength
and a lot of balance in your legs they
will improve your posture a lot improve
your core
and also improve your coordination
with the work of torsion to each side
okay
so i hope that you liked today's class
practice a lot thank you for watching
and i will see you in the next video bye